turkey is presidential contenders are
making their final pitches ahead of
Sunday's runoff election voters will
choose between president for Egypt
erdogan and Kamala kalichita ulum
erdogan is hoping to extend his 20 years
in power he's backed by sanan Iran who
finished third in the first round
has the support of the small far-right
victory party the opposition leader is
promising to increase security and
Deport Syrian refugees
has more on the challenges Kamala kalist
faces in the runoff against President
erdogan
he has asked people to vote for him
promising that he's going to bring more
freedoms more democracy into turkey and
a promise to fix the economy now the
first round came as a massive setback
for him so he is trading erdogan with
somehow like 2.2 million votes and he
saw a spectacular rise of the ultra
nationalist if he's going to tell the
ultra nationalist he's going to lose the
votes of the Kurds and vice versa this
explained why he has embraced a tough
anti-immigration tone over the last few
days now just simple math here if he
wants to win he has to have all the
votes of synonym and just to remind our
viewers was the third contender in the
first run and he got 5.2 percent of the
votes something like 2.5 million votes
is going to be extremely difficult for
uh kamales and he has been in over the
last few days accusing the government of
blocking his text messages to his
followers to his supporters and he said
that the government Watchdog is doing
this on recommendations from president
erdogan to deny him a chance to explain
his vision for the future of turkey now
to sum it up if you look at the latest
figures if you look at the situation on
the ground
women's confident that he's going to be
re-elected
on the things his supporters do
understand that this is going to be an
extremely delicate task ahead